Laurie Hernandez experiences her first
prom
while maureen mccormick is sent packing
on Dancing with the Stars it's something
I never ever thought I could do
on Monday night's episode of the
competition show Laurie and Val
performed an epic 1960s prom inspired
quickstep
and the 16 year old Olympian revealed
she's never actually been to the coveted
high school dance I don't go to high
school I homeschool I never been to prom
these are magic moments every teenager
should experience the judges love the
adorable performance giving the couple a
34 out of 40 each II spoke with Laurie
backstage after the show it was your
first ever prom yeah why would I'm not
really sure what to expect from prom
because I've never been in the front but
it was exciting I mean I guess I did its
best to expect the croissant of those so
that was a pretty cool fire it was valid
decent age did he treat you right did he
you know buy you the flowers that you
wanted yeah I got me the flowers he
asked my mom what my curfew was it was
great meanwhile country singer Jana
Kramer who continuously kills it in the
ballroom landed in the bottom two with
Brady Bunch star maureen McCormick the
couple leaving right now is Lori and
Harden
et spoke with Maureen backstage after
the elimination where she gushed over
being a part of the show what a great
way to you know leave and and to have
been a part of a beautiful beautiful
dance
you